I'm going to talk about L-renatamab, and these are my disclosures.
And for those who are less familiar with myeloma therapies, L-renatamab is another BCMA-directed
bispecific.
I guess the whole section is talking about BCMA-directed bispecifics.
And it was approved in August of 2023 following results of the Phase II Magnetism III or MM3
trial, which showed an overall response rate of about 61%.
But as time has gone on, these were the first kind of graphs that showed this plateau or
flattening effect that we talked about earlier, where we were seeing that these patients who'd
had a median of five prior lines of therapy were having durability of remissions that
was something very different.
And so in that context, we have a very effective therapy that's moved into very active development.
So in talking about ongoing trials, there's a lot to cover.
My other disclosure is that I needed Claude to help me make this.
This slide, because there's too many things going on.
So if there's any typos, I blame Dario Amode as well.
But to break this down a little bit more, in terms of ongoing trials that are most impactful
to be aware of, in the relapse refractory setting, we have two different confirmatory
Phase IIIs that are ongoing in the early relapse setting, the Magnetism V and Magnetism 32 trials.
Magnetism V is ELRA versus ELRA plus DERA versus EPD.
I don't think EPD stands much chance, but it will be pretty interesting.
We're going to see some head to head data comparing single agent BCMA bispecific versus
a BCMA bispecific plus a CD38 monoclonal.
Magnetism 32 is ELRA versus investigator's choice of EPD, PVD, KD.
In the newly diagnosed setting, Magnetism VI was mentioned this morning.
This is ELRA/DERA/LEN versus DERA/LEN/DEX in transplant and eligible newly diagnosed
patients.
Also mentioned was Magnetism VII, which is a randomized comparison between ELRA and lenalidomide
in a maintenance setting.
Thank you.
Two kind of interesting ongoing more sort of investigator or cooperative group sponsored
trials or European group sponsored trials, the ELLEN trial and FASTER are both starting
to answer that question of comparison versus transplant and versus maintenance after transplant.
And then to talk about some combination data that's in smaller groups of patients, but
I think pretty informative, hopefully.
Magnetism XX with carfilzomib and Magnetism XXX with ibertamide.
So to talk a bit about...
I think we're going to talk about the different types of carfilzomib and carfilzomib.
I think we're going to talk about the different types of carfilzomib.